[Musique]
quelle émotion génère la musique l'opéra
de montréal but littéralement entrer
dans la tête de ses spectateurs
comment la technologie peut nous aider à
combler les moments qui sont peut-être
un petit peu moins
waouh dans l'expérience opéra l'activité
cérébrale de 25 participants sera
mesurée pour comparer l'expérience opéra
entre une représentation en salles de
carmen et une autre devant un grand
écran
cette étude est menée par le laboratoire
de recherche de hec et un chercheur
américain spécialisé en neurosciences et
en musique pour ce projet un laboratoire
entier a déménagé ici dans les locaux de
l'opéra toutes les étapes sont cruciales
il faut prendre les mesures de la tête
du parti pour avoir le bon le bon en
fait tu casses de ben tu vas avoir sur
la tête et après aujourd'hui les
assistantes en ce moment sont en train
de mettre appliquée en fait du gel pour
que les électrodes puisse bien capté
d'activité cérébrale du participant
après avoir fait des tests scanner son
crâne
le participant saita dans la salle félix
s'est placé dans son siège quand tu vas
faire son expérience et on vient de le
calibrer avec les outils l'oculométrie
le mettreen permet de savoir où est le
lien le participant si jamais felix
avait une impulsion particulière qu'est
ce qu'on verrait sur le graphique on va
savoir quelle zone du cerveau étaient
activées qu'elle est et non pas est
activée
notre enjeu avec ce projet c'est
vraiment de comprendre tous les petits
leviers qu'on peut avoir pour convaincre
les gens de revenir de plus en plus de
développer un sentiment d'attachement et
d'engagement envers le père montréal
pour éventuellement être capable de les
faire revenir éventuellement qui
deviennent des abonnés près de 150 ans
après sa création
sera-t-il possible de comprendre ce qui
nous touche dans l'opéra carmen la
réponse peut-être dans un an lors de la
publication des résultats ici julie
jasmin boudreau radio canada montréal
[Musique]